- [Instructor] Right over
here, figure b is a scaled copy
of figure a.
What we want to do is figure out
what is the scale factor to
go from figure a to figure b?
Pause the video and see if
you can figure that out.
All we have to do is look
at corresponding sides
and think about how much
they have been scaled by.
For example, this side right over here
would correspond to this side
right over here on figure b.
And over here, it had length two
and over here it has
length one, two three,
four, five, six.
So, it look like that
side has been scaled up
by a factor of three.
If figure b truly is a scaled copy,
then every side should be
scaled up by a factor of three.
We could verify that.
We don't have to do it with every side.
We're being told that
these are scaled copies
but we can see that this is the case.
For example, this side right over here,
corresponds to this base right over here.
This has length three.
So, if we're scaling up
by a factor of three,
we should multiply that by three
and this should be of length nine.
Let's see if that's the case.
One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, and nine.
So, you can see, we can feel pretty good
that figure b is a scaled copy of figure a
and that scaling factor is three.